in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused
the moisture was good the
commodity prices were real good and we
happened to
gamble at the right time and it was one
where
we probably shouldn't have gotten as
many sales as we did but it was because
of some of our loaner programs where
instead of taking the guys that tractors
broke down on the used tractor that we
had we took them a new one you know by
the time we got to
uh use one back they said we'll just
just keep it and it's one word
you don't know until you try
and a lot of these guys won't be able to
make up their mind until it's sitting
there and they put on
10 15 hours on it and realize you know
what maybe i can do this
money happens to be there or sometimes
you might not realize that sale right
away it might be a year down the road
but if the seed is planted
that's all you can hope for is that it
will grow and it'll get you something to
come back with
because
that growth for us
yeah is exceptional and
do we
do we know if we'll ever have another
year like it you know we sure hope we do
it we hope we can improve on that
but
at the same time we're
we're optimists but we're we're still
witnessed and if we can't go forward and
realize that we might not have another
good year like that we are being
truthful to ourselves and that's the
biggest thing we're honest with
ourselves we can be honest with
everybody
the main thing about the growth that's a
great great number what have you
we measure our growth with customer
satisfaction
the customers are happy
tell your neighbor if you're upset
call me
call kemp that's what we're here for
because at the end of the day that's all
that matters i mean
we're here
we chose the profession to sell
equipment
in a rural area which is probably not
the most glamorous for some people
but you know what it's a great place to
raise your family the employees love it
the some of the other amenities that we
have around here hunting fishing you
know
hear the birds sing so to speak on it
which would drive a lot of people crazy
but if we didn't love what we were doing
we wouldn't be here and the customers is
our testament to it with our sales and
things like that thing there at the end
of the day what we need to do to be
successful
in a small community in the pacific
northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles
by being the best and by being honest to
their customers
dis
technology driven
people focused
you